Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
其他人：喂你好
Others: Hello, hi.
其他人：外卖到了
Others: The delivery is here.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来了
Jake: Coming.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:竹哥这些大充电宝哪去了
Jake: Hey, where did all the big power banks go?
Jake:我怎么找不着全了
Jake: I can't seem to find them.
其他人：这边昨天这边充了7个
Others: Over there, charged seven of them yesterday.
Jake:帮忙搞搞呗
Jake: Help me find them.
Jake:谢谢再见
Jake: Thank you, goodbye.
Jake:我大充电宝怎么一个都找不到啊
Jake: Why can't I find any of my power banks?
Jake:就一层的
Jake: Just on the first floor.
Jake:他应该有10个
Jake: There should be 10 of them.
Jake:二层我给他塞了
Jake: I put 5 on the second floor.
Jake:就5个吧
Jake: Only 5 left.
Jake:剩下5个没了
Jake: The remaining 5 are gone.
Jake:在哪里呢
Jake: Where are they?
其他人：一个夹子
Others: A clip.
其他人：然后应该是两根的线
Others: And there should be two wires.
Jake:一个是充电的线
Jake: One is the charging wire.
Jake:一个是踏板连着踏板的线
Jake: The other one connects the pedals.
Jake:你好戴眼镜吧
Jake: Hello, do you wear glasses?
Jake:你的眼镜
Jake: Your glasses.
Jake:你戴隐形眼镜了吗
Jake: Are you wearing contact lenses?
Jake:快快快
Jake: Hurry up, hurry up.
Jake:擦擦擦
Jake: Wipe, wipe, wipe.
Jake:所以在这里
Jake: So it's here.
Shure: 这个眼镜布和苹果官网的145的
Shure: This glasses cloth and the one from the Apple store for 145.
Jake:没用过那个你用过吗
Jake: I haven't used that one, have you?
Shure: 我见过
Shure: I've seen it.
Jake:哈哈哈好看吗
Jake: Haha, does it look good?
Shure: 好看
Shure: It looks good.
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: So fancy?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 就是买的那种华强北29的和145的
Shure: The ones bought from Huaqiangbei for 29 and the one for 145.
Shure: 放显微镜下纤维它确实是不一样的
Shure: Under a microscope, the fibers are indeed different.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:他至少是不一样的
Jake: They are at least different.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:好或者不好咱就不好说了
Jake: Whether they're good or not, we can't really say.
Shure: 就是i非常的规整
Shure: It's just that i is very neat.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:精细工艺
Jake: Fine craftsmanship.
Jake:吃包子吗
Jake: Want some buns?
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:啊在这
Jake: Ah, here you go.
Jake:怎么了
Jake: What's up?
Tasha: 不知道什么时候划伤的
Tasha: I don't know when I got scratched.
Shure: 我这有创可贴要吗
Shure: I have a band-aid, do you want one?
Jake:他这么大
Jake: It's so big.
Jake:创可贴
Jake: A band-aid.
Jake:呵呵呵是不是不够啊
Jake: Haha, is it not enough?
Jake:创可贴呵呵是不是
Jake: A band-aid, haha, right?
Jake:哈哈哈是不是
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake:是得上医院吗
Jake: Do we need to go to the hospital?
Jake:哈哈打个针
Jake: Haha, get a shot.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 不好你还在录啊我靠
Tasha: Oh no, you're still recording, damn.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 到时候给你恶意剪辑
Shure: We'll edit it maliciously later.
Tasha: 恶意剪辑啊
Tasha: Malicious editing, huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 不上医院
Shure: No hospital.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:谢斌竹咱充电宝怎么这么少啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu, why do we have so few power banks?
其他人：上面都有大充电宝
Others: There are big power banks upstairs.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:这太少了
Jake: This is too few.
Jake:昨天昨天一楼充电宝没收完
Jake: Yesterday, we didn’t collect all the power banks on the first floor.
Jake:沙雕
Jake: Idiot.
Shure: 临行前我我可以拿一
Shure: Before leaving, can I take one?
Shure: 个充电宝作为系统
Shure: A power bank as a system?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake:哦你还有个20的充电宝
Jake: Oh, you have a 20,000 mAh power bank?
Jake:呵呵呵多少多少有点
Jake: Haha, how much, how much?
Jake:他在一边充一边
Jake: You charge while...
Jake:一边充充电宝一边给电吗
Jake: You charge the power bank while giving power?
Shure: 能
Shure: Yes.
Jake:这真能
Jake: It really works.
Jake:那那那那那充充充一点
Jake: Then, then, then, charge, charge a bit.
Jake:怎么充啊
Jake: How do you charge it?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Jake:怎么搞啊
Jake: How do you do it?
Katrina: 面包在这里
Katrina: The bread is here.
Jake:你有一个朋友
Jake: You have a friend.
Katrina: 我怎么了
Katrina: What's up with me?
Jake:有一个朋友
Jake: There's a friend
Katrina: 我给你讲什么故事
Katrina: What story should I tell you?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 我说我朋友怎么了
Katrina: I said what happened to my friend?
Jake:敌友亦有
Jake: Friend or foe
Jake:你没有朋友我有
Jake: You don't have friends, but I do
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have
Jake:有你有一个朋友啊
Jake: You have a friend, huh
Shure: 我也有一个朋友
Shure: I also have a friend
Jake:你就啊你有一个朋友
Jake: Yeah, you have a friend
Jake:好你们都有一个朋友
Jake: Okay, you all have a friend
Jake:谢斌竹没有朋友
Jake: Xie Binzhu has no friends
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 能别刺激人家了
Katrina: Can you stop teasing him?
Katrina: 没有牛奶了吗
Katrina: No more milk?
Katrina: 这是点的早饭
Katrina: This is the breakfast we ordered
Jake:对这早饭粥
Jake: Yes, this breakfast porridge
Katrina: 啊啊啊
Katrina: Ah ah ah
Jake:对吃吧
Jake: Yeah, eat up
Katrina: 有早饭
Katrina: There's breakfast
Jake:对包子对
Jake: Yes, buns
Katrina: 这有牛奶
Katrina: There's milk here
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello
Jake:哎哈喽
Jake:要要要要
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake:OK OK你在哪啊
Jake: OK OK, where are you?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 微信加坡的电话
Katrina: It's a call from Singapore
Jake:是新加坡的
Jake: It's from Singapore
Jake:然后给我说中文了
Jake: And they spoke to me in Chinese
Jake:哎你好啊
Jake: Hey, hello
Jake:你继续吧然后呢
Jake: You continue, so then
Jake:啊对对对对对是您说
Jake: Ah, right, right, right, you say
Jake:啊好好
Jake: Ah, alright, alright
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright
Jake:呃行但我现在在国内啊
Jake: Uh, but I'm currently in the mainland
Jake:我国内我我过来大概要半个月吧
Jake: I'm in the mainland, it'll take me about half a month to get there
Jake:呃对对是
Jake: Uh, yes, yes
Katrina: 这薯条扔了吗
Katrina: Did you throw away these fries?
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah ah.
Jake:听不懂听不懂
Jake: I don't understand, I don't understand.
Jake:你说英文吧要不
Jake: How about you speak English?
Tasha: 说英文吧
Tasha: Speak English.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 这是什么点的烤红薯
Katrina: What kind of roasted sweet potato is this?
Tasha: 搞什么
Tasha: What's going on?
Jake:哈
Jake:我逗他玩呢
Jake: I'm messing with him.
Jake:我靠真的
Jake: Oh my gosh, really.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Jake:对他撂了
Jake: Yeah, he hung up.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 业务能力不大过关
Katrina: His skills aren't that great.
Katrina: 油条
Katrina: Fried dough sticks.
Jake:他就会说个哈喽哈哈哈
Jake: He can only say "hello" and laugh, haha.
Katrina: 哈喽哈哈哈
Katrina: Hello, haha.
Tasha: 你放心
Tasha: Don't worry.
Tasha: 今天晚上我一定会把它吃掉的
Tasha: I'll definitely finish it tonight.
Katrina: 这怎么分啊
Katrina: How do we divide this?
Katrina: 这个粥这么大拿碗
Katrina: This porridge is so big, get a bowl.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 你放心明天早上8点一定会叫你的
Shure: Don't worry, I'll wake you up at 8 AM tomorrow.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Jake:哈哈哈昨日重现啊这是
Jake: Hahaha, it's like a replay of yesterday.
Tasha: 明天早上
Tasha: Tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 一定可以的
Katrina: It'll be fine.
Katrina: 我也定了闹钟
Katrina: I set an alarm too.
Jake:看看你的快递
Jake: Check your delivery.
Katrina: 了
Katrina: Okay.
Tasha: 这是石头剪刀布
Tasha: This is rock-paper-scissors.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Katrina: 没醒
Katrina: Didn't wake up.
Katrina: 按了定了4个闹钟全按了
Katrina: Set four alarms and turned them all off.
Tasha: 垃圾转移
Tasha: Trash transfer.
Katrina: 看一下这
Katrina: Take a look at this.
Shure: 咱们来写之前就得收拾收拾
Shure: We need to tidy up before we start writing.
Shure: 就给我们的顾客看看这个
Shure: Let's show this to our customers.
Tasha: 看这个
Tasha: Look at this.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 想吃什么自己拿
Tasha: If you want to eat, just take it yourself.
Jake:盛情招待
Jake: Our warm hospitality.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈随便吃
Jake: Hahaha, help yourself.
Jake:哈哈随便吃
Jake:随自己烤
Jake: Grill it yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 许愿一下
Katrina: Make a wish.
Jake:还剩两个包子
Jake: There are still two buns left.
Alice:有早饭吗
Alice: Is there breakfast?
Katrina: 好久没吃油条了
Katrina: Haven't had fried dough sticks in a long time.
其他人： 你来吗
Others: Are you coming?
Katrina: 急的谢斌竹现场摇人了
Katrina: Xie Bin is so anxious, he's calling people live.
Shure: 然后我那个桌上那瓶伏特加也放了
Shure: And I put that bottle of vodka on the table.
Tasha: 音响呢不是说拿音响来吗
Tasha: Where's the speaker? Weren't we supposed to bring the speaker?
Tasha: 音响
Tasha: The speaker.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:准备发售了
Jake: Getting ready to release.
Jake:我们少了很多充电宝
Jake: We're missing a lot of power banks.
Jake:不知道发生了什么
Jake: No idea what happened.
Tasha: 我还想说我少了很多皮筋呢
Tasha: I was about to say, I'm missing a lot of hair ties too.
Tasha: 我带过来至少10根不下皮筋今天
Tasha: I brought at least 10 hair ties today.
Jake:这充电宝咋还没送呢
Jake: Why haven't the power banks been delivered?
Jake:就没了呵呵呵
Jake: They're just gone, haha.
Tasha: 今天只剩最后一根了
Tasha: Today there's only one left.
Katrina: 我拆掉了
Katrina: I took them apart.
Tasha: 我想扎个双马尾都扎不了
Tasha: I can't even tie a double ponytail.
Jake:骗哦多少钱
Jake: How much are you scamming?
Jake:哦这么少
Jake: Oh, that little.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This.
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome.
Jake:炒币呢
Jake: Trading coins?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：这是拿命玩
Others: This is risking your life.
Jake:波动这么大
Jake: Such big fluctuations.
Katrina: 怎么
Katrina: How?
其他人：就还好昨天晚上蹲到一个点
Others: Well, luckily last night we reached a point.
Jake:蹲到0.18 然后及时死了哦
Jake: Got to 0.18, and then it died out in time.
Katrina: 玩
Katrina: Playing.
Katrina: 我一直想知道挖臂的原理是什么
Katrina: I've always wanted to know how mining works.
其他人：然后你算到了前面多少位
Others: So, how many digits did you calculate up to?
其他人：是他指定的保险
Others: It's the insurance he specified.
其他人：你就OK了
Others: Then you're good to go.
Jake:你就碰上了
Jake: You've got it.
Jake:然后这就是你的了
Jake: And then it's yours.
Katrina: 啊那些程序算那东西啊
Katrina: Oh, those programs calculate that stuff?
Jake:这
Jake: This.
Jake:哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, alright.
Jake:他会办掉你吗
Jake: Will he take you out?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Jake:反正你不用
Jake: You don't need to anyway.
Shure: 他肯定在监控
Shure: He's definitely monitoring.
Jake:他肯定在监
Jake: He's definitely moni-
Katrina: 那它这个币的价格怎么定呢
Katrina: So, how is the price of this coin determined?
其他人：币的价格就是共存在你的
Others: The price of the coin is based on what's stored with you.
Katrina: 啊就是看你挖到那别人有没有挖到
Katrina: Oh, it depends on whether others have mined it too?
Katrina: 就同同个时间多少人
Katrina: Like, how many people at the same time.
其他人：这个币的价值在于你觉得这个币未来
Others: The value of this coin depends on how you see its future.
其他人：嗯你觉得大家都觉得这个比未来好
Others: If everyone believes in its future value.
其他人：那他不就更实际吗
Others: Then it becomes more practical.
其他人：比如说我们ego币
Others: For example, our ego coin.
其他人：一开始一分不值
Others: It was worthless at first.
其他人：但大家在二手物品非常的屌哎
Others: But everyone thought it was amazing in second-hand goods.
其他人：这ego币就很有价值
Others: So ego coin became valuable.
其他人：可能一开始刚拍
Others: Maybe at the beginning, it was just
其他人：拍第一轮是将10个一个币
Others: the first round, 10 for a coin.
其他人：后来大家越来越少
Others: Then fewer and fewer people.
其他人：突然有一个杀掉一个
Others: Suddenly someone kills one.
其他人：一个币就换下了一个大东西
Others: One coin exchanged for something big.
其他人：然后整体就升值
Others: Then the overall value increased.
Shure: 存货缩水是吧
Shure: So the inventory shrinks, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:虽然不知道
Jake: Although I don't know
Jake:但是听起来不是
Jake: But it doesn't sound like it
Alice:有人喝粥吗
Alice: Does anyone want some porridge?
Alice:我想喝咸的
Alice: I want something savory
Jake:喝喝呵呵呵
Jake: Drink, drink, hahaha
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha
Jake:银耳汤
Jake: White fungus soup
Alice:银耳汤
Alice: White fungus soup
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Katrina: 这个好吃
Katrina: This is delicious
Katrina: 皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: Century egg and lean pork congee
Alice:嗯可咸了
Alice: Yeah, it's really savory
Katrina: 我也想喝皮蛋瘦肉粥
Katrina: I want some century egg and lean pork congee too
Alice:拿个碗倒一下
Alice: Grab a bowl and pour some
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn
Jake:你看他是要在群里发的
Jake: Look, he's going to post it in the group
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Damn, damn
Jake:哈哈哈壮观哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, so grand, hahaha
Alice:那个里面没了
Alice: It's all gone inside
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:刷卡
Jake: Swipe the card
其他人：okay in your
Others: okay in your
Jake:手机号
Jake: Phone number
Jake:overseas Chinese bank
Jake: Overseas Chinese bank
Katrina: 勺子的
Katrina: Of the spoon
Shure: 有他的这个全部信息
Shure: He has all this information
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, he does
Jake:但是他没有眼镜
Jake:你现在有是吗
Jake: Do you have them now?
Jake:你没插电
Jake: You didn't plug it in
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 我开
Shure: I'll open it
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:approved
Jake: Approved
Shure: 这个司机
Shure: This driver
Shure: 夹头发跟那个买弹力
Shure: Clips hair and buys elastic bands
Shure: 买反馈嗯
Shure: Buys feedback, hmm
Jake:只是戴眼镜有真实感
Jake: Wearing glasses makes it more realistic
Tasha: 真的没有办法工作了
Tasha: I really can't work anymore
Jake:卧槽涨了
Jake: Damn, it went up
Jake:已经涨了啊
Jake: It's already gone up.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Damn, damn.
Jake:刚买就暴跌
Jake: Just bought it and it plummeted.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha.
Jake:哈啊
Jake: Ha.
其他人：这个还没配啊
Others: This hasn't been allocated yet.
其他人：个我只是买了一点笔还没付出去
Others: I just bought a little, haven't paid yet.
Jake:所以还能再买是吧
Jake: So we can still buy more, right?
其他人：现在就是还能有结余
Others: Yeah, there's still a balance left.
其他人：就我刚只是在充纸币
Others: I was just topping up with paper money.
Jake:哦哦还没买
Jake: Oh, haven't bought yet.
Jake:是还没买
Jake: Yeah, haven't bought yet.
其他人：对哦还没买就可以有个低价购入
Others: Yeah, we can buy at a lower price.
其他人：哎到货了
Others: Hey, it's arrived.
Katrina: 到货了
Katrina: It's arrived.
Katrina: 看看到货是啥样
Katrina: Let's see what it looks like.
其他人：然后赶紧给你买
Others: Then quickly buy it for you.
其他人：还能结余这么多笔
Others: There's still so much left.
其他人：我草要不要再他妈等一下
Others: Damn, should we wait a bit longer?
Katrina: ETH是什么意思
Katrina: What's ETH?
Katrina: 就是货币单位
Katrina: It's a currency unit.
Jake:以太坊
Jake: Ethereum.
Jake:以太坊大概就是跟比特币绑定了
Jake: Ethereum is basically tied to Bitcoin.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：买上了
Others: Bought it.
Jake:买到了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got the money.
其他人：钱没了
Others: Money's gone.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：这个单颗80刀吧
Others: This one is 80 bucks each.
其他人：美刀新加坡的
Others: US dollars, from Singapore.
Jake:新刀嗯
Jake:就按照按照您这边汇率的话就480
Jake: According to your exchange rate, that's 480.
Jake:我就哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:你汇率跟别人不一样哈哈
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好喝
Katrina: This century egg and lean pork congee is pretty good.
Katrina: 这皮蛋瘦肉粥还挺好
Katrina: This congee is really nice.
其他人：哎你到了
Others: Hey, you're here.
其他人：你给哥你找出来
Others: You find it for bro.
Katrina: 喝
Katrina: Drink.
其他人：留一个短头发的女生带动吧
Others: Let's have a short-haired girl lead.
其他人：要不你打个视频
Others: How about you make a video call?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 我想死你了
Shure: I missed you so much.
Shure: 我太想你了
Shure: I really missed you.
Shure: 都拿什么了
Shure: What did you get?
Shure: 你傻子傻子
Shure: You silly, silly.
其他人：哦你远远远一下我瞅瞅
Others: Oh, step back a bit so I can take a look.
其他人：呃他可能在学校里面
Others: Uh, he might be at school.
Shure: 我很想你
Shure: I really miss you.
Shure: 大哥能让我看看你吗
Shure: Bro, can you let me see you?
Shure: 天呐你果然趟黑人趟去了
Shure: Oh my god, you actually went to hang out with Black people 种族宗教问题
Shure: 我每天都在被窝里流眼泪
Shure: I cry in bed every day.
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Jake:您的眼镜对
Jake: Your glasses, right.
Shure: 没有我给你的分身打电话
Shure: I called your clone.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:想他嘴巴也行
Jake: Thinking about his mouth is fine too.
Jake:说的话选b调
Jake: Choose the b tone when speaking.
Shure: 好坚决啊
Shure: So decisive.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What happened?
Jake:买了
Jake: Bought it.
其他人：已经有了
Others: Already have it.
Jake:什么叫有了
Jake: What do you mean by have it?
Jake:有人已经有人买了
Jake: Someone already bought it.
Jake:那不是呵呵呵
Jake: Isn't that haha.
其他人：我说我现在账户里已经有150个ego币了
Others: I mean I already have 150 ego coins in my account now.
Jake:哦牛批
Jake: Oh, impressive.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Nice, nice.
Shure: 然后呢然后我们怎么分发呢
Shure: So, how do we distribute them?
Shure: 最后会有有
Shure: Finally, we'll have...
Shure: 有这个Matt mask的就分
Shure: We'll distribute to those who have the Matt mask.
Shure: 没有的就不分是吧
Shure: And not to those who don't, right?
其他人：我的想法是
Others: My thought is...
其他人：最后
Others: Finally...
其他人：今天大家每个人最后手里有多少个ego币
Others: Today, everyone will have a certain amount of ego coins in their hands.
Shure: 那怎么发呢
Shure: How will we distribute them?
Shure: 那万一有人没有这个钱包呢
Shure: What if someone doesn't have the wallet?
其他人：发钱包也不
Others: Distribute wallets too...
其他人：要钱
Other: Want money
其他人：但我不知道这个
Other: But I don't know this
其他人：发钱包会不会要燃油费啊
Other: Will sending a wallet require a fuel fee?
其他人：也他妈发一个
Other: Send one too, damn it
其他人：ego币不要钱
Other: ego coin doesn't cost money
其他人：燃油费他妈
Other: Damn fuel fee
其他人：那没事我还有
Other: It's okay, I still have some
Shure: 知道这个是干嘛的吗
Shure: Do you know what this is for?
其他人：测温的
Other: Measuring temperature
其他人： 那你加一个面包我要先吃一下
Other: Then add a bread, I need to eat first
Shure: 我有
Shure: I have it
Katrina: 你知道这这孔怎么打开吗
Katrina: Do you know how to open this hole?
Katrina: 没明白它的构造
Katrina: I don't understand its structure
Jake:应该是有一个针
Jake: There should be a pin
Jake:它应该是有一个它
Jake: There should be one of these
Jake:它就一个这个东西吗
Jake: Is it just this thing?
Katrina: 嗯刚刚就把他下面这一环给撕了
Katrina: Yeah, I just tore off the ring below
Katrina: 但是好像没有送针啊
Katrina: But it seems like there's no pin
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
其他人：呃
Other: Ugh
其他人：我们的成本上这币每个都已经3块钱
Other: Our cost for this thing is already 3 yuan each
Jake:有点贵有点稍贵
Jake: A bit expensive, slightly expensive
Jake:嗯你知道怎么开吗这东西
Jake: Um, do you know how to open this thing?
Katrina: 你知道怎么开吗
Katrina: Do you know how to open it?
Katrina: 这种就是他这个孔怎么打开
Katrina: How to open this hole?
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 其实我觉得说的有道理
Katrina: Actually, I think it makes sense
Katrina: 直接渡我就行
Katrina: Just guide me directly
Jake:这什么东西
Jake: What's this?
Shure: OK了来吧
Shure: It's okay, let's go
Jake:哦哦可以我拿了
Jake: Oh okay, I got it
Jake:我靠这红薯长成这样
Jake: Wow, this sweet potato grew like this
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah yes
Lucia: 他确实是烤红薯
Lucia: It's really a roasted sweet potato
Lucia: 哇这个银耳雪梨汤
Lucia: Wow, this silver ear pear soup
Lucia: 它里面竟然是整颗雪梨
Lucia: It actually has a whole pear inside
Jake:哈哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my
Lucia: 我去
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia: 这比巧克力宣传整颗榛子还离谱
Lucia: This is crazier than the chocolate with a whole hazelnut
Lucia: 因为它真的是整颗雪梨
Lucia: Because it really is a whole pear
Lucia: 你看我一捞上来我就惊呆了
Lucia: Look, I was stunned when I scooped it up.
Jake:吃应该比较好分吧
Jake: Eating it should be pretty easy, right?
Jake:要自己分就很离谱
Jake: It's ridiculous if we have to divide it ourselves.
Shure: 燃油费要多少
Shure: How much is the fuel cost?
其他人：最后一次
Others: One last time.
Katrina: 我需要充电宝
Katrina: I need a power bank.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:但是我们没什么充电宝
Jake: But we don't have many power banks.
其他人：这他妈得多少钱啊
Others: How much does this cost, damn it?
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Jake:你要不找一个叉子
Jake: Why don't you find a fork?
Jake:你要不找一个固定的叉子
Jake: Why don't you find a fixed fork?
Jake:你要是你活动
Jake: If you are moving around.
Katrina: 在外面
Katrina: Outside.
Jake:你在外面
Jake: You are outside.
Jake:暂时还不着急
Jake: No rush for now.
Katrina: 那等会
Katrina: Then later.
Jake:哎怎么没有充电宝
Jake: Hey, why don't we have any power banks?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:来整俩充电宝
Jake: Get two power banks.
Shure: 只要我靠谱
Shure: As long as I'm reliable.
Shure: 这个币就有价值
Shure: This coin will have value.
Jake:你怎么靠谱
Jake: How are you reliable?
Shure: 因为我现在就必须得
Shure: Because I have to do it now.
Jake:记住每个人多少钱
Jake: Remember how much everyone owes.
Shure: 我妈
Shure: My mom.
Jake:我没办法直接给他们
Jake: I can't directly give it to them.
Jake:啊直接给他们他妈太坑
Jake: Ah, giving it directly to them is such a rip-off.
Alice:妈
Alice: Mom.
Jake:那那怎么办
Jake: Then what should we do?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哎这是啥呀
Jake: Hey, what is this?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 看起来好像可以用的样子
Lucia: It looks like it can be used.
Jake:呀yes
Jake: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 我可以先把它摘下来安一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it down and install it first?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:走拿快递去
Jake: Let's go pick up the package.
Lucia: 嗯又可以去拿快递了
Lucia: Hmm, we get to pick up the package again.
Jake:呃因为他
Jake: Uh, because he...
Jake:有很
Jake: has a lot...
Jake:你看你看他的快递你看他的快递
Jake: Look, look at his package, look at his package.
Tasha: 昨天没有人替我拿
Tasha: No one picked mine up yesterday.
Lucia: 昨天我的也没拿
Lucia: Mine wasn't picked up yesterday either.
Lucia: 所以我就专门去拿了一套
Lucia: So I went to pick up a set myself.
Lucia: 对我当时应该把这边的一块拿上
Lucia: Yeah, I should've picked up the one here too.
Lucia: 我以为他们给你拿了呢
Lucia: I thought they picked it up for you.
Lucia: 就是那个民宿的
Lucia: The one from the guesthouse.
Tasha: 谁给我拿了
Tasha: Who picked it up for me?
Lucia: 民宿的
Lucia: The guesthouse.
Lucia: 本来民宿的
Lucia: The guesthouse was supposed to...
Lucia: supposed to拿我们所有人的快递
Lucia: was supposed to pick up all our packages.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 你昨天应该说一声
Lucia: You should have said something yesterday.
Lucia: 我要知道你没拿我们就
Lucia: If I knew you didn't pick it up, we would've...
Tasha: 给他打电话了
Tasha: called him.
Lucia: 领导这是你的你的问题了
Lucia: Boss, this is your problem now.
Lucia: 领导你反思哈哈哈
Lucia: Boss, you need to reflect, haha.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Hmm, yes.
Jake:我反思反思
Jake: I will reflect, reflect.
Lucia: 我那这么说来他们昨天就没拿几个
Lucia: So they didn't pick up much yesterday.
Lucia: 咱俩那一串都没拿
Lucia: They didn't pick up our whole batch.
Lucia: 就那个民宿
Lucia: Just the guesthouse ones.
Jake:你昨天发的那一串他啥也没拿是吧
Jake: The whole batch you sent yesterday, they didn't pick up any of it, right?
Lucia: 我也
Lucia: I also...
Lucia: 我觉得民宿
Lucia: I think the guesthouse...
Lucia: 他们这个工作态度要提升一下呀
Lucia: Their work attitude needs improvement.
Jake:有问题
Jake: There's a problem.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:下一次去三亚就不找他们了
Jake: Next time we go to Sanya, we won't use them.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 我们真的要去三亚吗
Lucia: Are we really going to Sanya?
Lucia: 还没有去过
Lucia: I've never been.
Jake:你没有去过
Jake: You've never been?
Lucia: 没去过
Lucia: Never.
Jake:没去过走
Jake: Never? Let's go.
Lucia: 所以您要是在三亚做实验的话
Lucia: So if you do an experiment in Sanya...
Lucia: 你看我这个工作态度和效率怎么样
Lucia: How do you think my work attitude and efficiency are?
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, it's good, it's good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈老板你考虑一下
Lucia: Hahaha, boss, think about it.
Shure: 什么什么时候去三亚呀老板
Shure: Boss, when are we going to Sanya?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:什么时候去
Jake: When are we going?
Jake:五一之后去走
Jake: We'll go after May Day.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake:真的啦
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Shure: 你等我答完辩的
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 我正好正好公费度蜜月去了怎么样
Shure: Perfect, I'll go on my company-sponsored honeymoon.
Tasha: 公费度蜜月
Tasha: Company-sponsored honeymoon?
Tasha: 你还要把你女朋友带上
Tasha: You're going to bring your girlfriend too?
Shure: 我们干活效率都很高
Shure: We work very efficiently.
Tasha: 哦是你啊
Tasha: Oh, it's you.
Tasha: 想看看是哪一位男生
Tasha: I want to see which guy it is.
Alice:啊累死我了
Alice: Ugh, I'm so tired.
Tasha: 你女朋友在北京吗
Tasha: Is your girlfriend in Beijing?
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Yeah, she is.
Tasha: 是的哦是她的
Tasha: Oh, is she?
Tasha: 在西安
Tasha: In Xi'an?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 啊我说是她的在西安
Tasha: Ah, I said she's in Xi'an.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Lucia: 他是女朋友在西安
Lucia: His girlfriend is in Xi'an.
Katrina: 我是
Katrina: I am.
Tasha: 他女朋友
Tasha: His girlfriend.
Lucia: 想认识一下美女小姐姐
Lucia: I want to meet the pretty girl.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为我在西安
Lucia: Hahaha, because I'm in Xi'an.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha: 我知道我说他怎么不说话
Tasha: I knew it, no wonder he wasn't talking.
Shure: 哎那你会说陕西话吗
Shure: Hey, can you speak Shaanxi dialect?
Lucia: 你会说陕西话吗
Lucia: Can you speak Shaanxi dialect?
Lucia: 我会但我说的可能不那么标准
Lucia: I can, but what I say might not be very standard.
Lucia: 不过北方话反正本来就是变的调
Lucia: Anyway, northern dialects are naturally varied.
Lucia: 怎么要我说一段吗哈哈
Lucia: So, do you want me to say something? Haha.
Jake:来来一段
Jake: Yes, go ahead.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green pepper buns.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈你这说啥我咋听不懂啊哈哈
Lucia: Haha, what are you saying? I don't understand. Haha.
Shure: 绿辣子6馍
Shure: Green pepper buns.
Shure: 什么那个
Shure: What was that?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia: 我我我因为我们家一般不说山西话
Lucia: Because my family generally doesn't speak the Shanxi dialect.
Tasha: 我在外面啊
Tasha: I'm outside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 就是只有只有我姥姥姥爷那一辈人
Lucia: Only my grandparents' generation speaks it.
Lucia: 他们才说山西话
Lucia: They are the ones who speak Shanxi dialect.
Lucia: 对所以我在家其实也说普通话
Lucia: So, at home, we actually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 就是说的就说的不是很标准
Lucia: But my Mandarin isn't very standard.
Lucia: 但是我同学都说
Lucia: However, my classmates say
Lucia: 说的还可以
Lucia: it's alright.
Lucia: 但是可能是同学给我给面子你知道吧
Lucia: But maybe they're just being nice, you know?
Jake:很标准了
Jake: It's very standard.
Shure: 完了武林外传的味上来了
Shure: Now it sounds like "My Own Swordsman."
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 佟掌柜哈哈哈
Shure: Tong Shopkeeper. Hahaha.
Jake:这太呵呵
Jake: That's so funny.
Shure: 你今天要不就一直这样
Shure: Why don't you keep talking like that today?
Shure: 我进来要来了呢
Shure: I'm getting into it.
Jake:要回大掌柜吧
Jake: You mean the chief shopkeeper?
Jake:要不啊呵呵呵
Jake: Or maybe, haha.
Shure: 你你比如说那个那个有有客人来了
Shure: For example, if a guest arrives,
Shure: 你会怎么说
Shure: how would you greet them?
Shure: 用用那个山西话啊
Shure: Using the Shanxi dialect, of course.
Shure: 不是陕西话
Shure: Not the Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 吃馍还是吃还是吃啥
Lucia: Would you like some buns, or something else?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 俺也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:他说下午统一取
Alice: He said to pick it up in the afternoon.
Alice:下午不就晚了
Alice: Isn't the afternoon too late?
Jake:对所以我们直接自己走
Jake: Yeah, so we'll just go by ourselves.
Alice:我有两个我的都到了
Alice: I have two, both of mine have arrived.
Jake:好吃吃吃吃
Jake: Great, eat, eat, eat.
Jake:能吃都能吃
Jake: You can eat, everything's edible.
Lucia: 这里面是整颗雪梨不过已经
Lucia: Inside there's a whole snow pear, but I've already eaten part of it.
Lucia: 被我吃掉了一部分
Lucia: I ate part of it already.
Alice:所以什么时候拿快递啊
Alice: So when are we picking up the package?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, I guess.
Jake:哎谢斌竹帮忙
Jake: Hey, Xie Bin Zhu, can you help?
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this one.
Jake:这你配过对吧
Jake: You paired this before, right?
Jake:怎怎么配
Jake: How do you pair it?
Jake:就是我要跟他建立一个蓝牙
Jake: I need to establish a Bluetooth connection with it.
Jake:他是没开吗
Jake: Is it not turned on?
Jake:他是咋回事
Jake: What's going on with it?
Jake:嗯牛逼了
Jake: Hmm, that's awesome.
Jake:可以吗可以
Jake: Is it okay? Yes, it is.
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Lucia: 这好像是个蛋羹
Lucia: This seems to be an egg custard.
Lucia: 吃这个需要放醋吧应该
Lucia: You should probably add vinegar to this.
Lucia: 他没给吗看一下
Lucia: Didn't they give you any? Let me check.
Jake:他包里好像还有东西
Jake: I think there's something else in the bag.
Lucia: 果然小醋包
Lucia: Sure enough, a small vinegar packet.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Mm, good.
Jake:拿快递了
Jake: Got the package.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:唉这没啥
Jake: Hey, it's nothing.
Lucia: 我可以申请帮我取一下吗
Lucia: Can I request someone to pick it up for me?
Jake:充点的好
Jake: It's better to recharge.
Lucia: 因为我要在家剪那个墙纸
Lucia: Because I need to stay home and cut the wallpaper.
Jake:行发
Jake: Sure, send it.
Jake:好嘞发给我
Jake: Alright, send it to me.
Lucia: 只有两个了谢谢
Lucia: Only two left, thanks.
Jake:谢谢好好好
Jake: Thank you, okay, okay.
Jake:发给我发给我
Jake: Send it to me, send it to me.
Shure: 怎么办
Shure: What should we do?
Jake:太少了我上去换一个下去
Jake: Too few, I'll go up and change one and come down.
其他人：不是吃东西的吧
Others: It's not something to eat, right?
Lucia: 不是吧昨天靖康给我的
Lucia: No, it’s not. Jingkang gave it to me yesterday.
Lucia: 应该不是用来吃东西
Lucia: It's probably not for eating.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What's this?
其他人：镊子
Others: Tweezers.
Jake:我不知道干嘛的
Jake: I don't know what it's for.
Lucia: 的
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 本来昨天打算拿它烤那个水母蛆
Lucia: I was planning to use it to grill the jellyfish maggots yesterday.
Lucia: 但是有点短
Lucia: But it's a bit short.
Jake:这是啥油条
Jake: What is this, fried dough sticks?
Lucia: 油条
Lucia: Fried dough sticks.
Jake:油条再整一个
Jake: Make another fried dough stick.
Jake:叼一个走
Jake: Grab one and go.
Jake:拿快递了
Jake: Picking up a package.
Jake:走走快递
Jake: Let's go get the package.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan.
Jake:在外边外边
Jake: It's outside, outside.
其他人：雨轩
Others: Yuxuan.
Jake:你有一个快递对吧
Jake: You have a package, right?
Katrina: 两个
Katrina: Two.
Jake:两个好
Jake: Two, okay.
Alice:我也有两个
Alice: I also have two.
Jake:你也有两个
Jake: You have two as well.
Lucia: 我发到你的聊天框里吧
Lucia: I'll send it to your chat box.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 谢谢非常感谢
Lucia: Thanks, really appreciate it.
Jake:没有关系
Jake: No problem.
Jake:吕翔还有快递吗
Jake: Lvxing, do you have any packages?
Katrina: 我的快递还没到
Katrina: My package hasn't arrived yet.
Jake:好你英文名
Jake: Okay, your English name.
Jake:你有英文名吗
Jake: Do you have an English name?
Katrina: 可以现场起
Katrina: I can make one up on the spot.
Katrina: 可以可以有
Katrina: Sure, I can have one.
Jake:嗯你哈哈哈
Jake: Hmm, you... hahaha
Katrina: 我给你是吧发给你
Katrina: I'll give it to you, right, I'll send it to you.
Jake:那你你你自己
Jake: Then you, you, you yourself.
Jake:现场起还是
Jake: Are you making it up on the spot or...
Katrina: 啊今天要
Katrina: Ah, today we need...
Katrina: 因为要用到吗还是怎么
Katrina: Because we need to use it today or what...
Jake:对要用一下
Jake: Yes, we need to use it.
Katrina: 啊等一会去
Katrina: Ah, wait a minute.
Jake:这么现场戏
Jake: How about on the spot.
Jake:那就那就叫
Jake: Then let's call it...
Jake:那就叫勾吧
Jake: Let's call it "Gou."
Jake:要不哈哈哈哈
Jake: Or hahaha...
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 太难听了
Katrina: That's too ugly.
Jake:j
Jake: J.
Katrina: 他要叫我勾
Katrina: He wants to call me "Gou."
Jake:英文名要给个英文名
Jake: It needs to be an English name.
其他人： 你有英文名啊你
Others: You have an English name!
Jake:你怎么没有英文名呢
Jake: How do you not have an English name?
Jake:想一想先起一个
Jake: Think of one first.
Jake:先起一个j
Jake: Just come up with one, J.
Jake:内蒙古Jesus Jesus啊
Jake: Inner Mongolia Jesus. Jesus.
其他人：Jesus
Others: Jesus.
Jake:好可以
Jake: Okay, that's good.
Jake:这有点牛逼
Jake: That's kinda cool.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece.
Jake:古希腊古希腊
Jake: Ancient Greece, Ancient Greece.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：古希腊掌管闹钟的神
Others: The god of alarm clocks in Ancient Greece.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's great.
Jake:好古希腊
Jake: Alright, Ancient Greece.
Jake:走走拿快递
Jake: Let's go, pick up the delivery.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:他太慢了
Jake: He's too slow.
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:够应该不够
Jake: Is it enough? Maybe not.
Jake:要不这样
Jake: How about this?
Jake:勾你来监工一下吧
Jake: Gou, you supervise for a bit.
Jake:怎么样古希腊
Jake: How about it, Ancient Greece?
Jake:你来监工一下吧
Katrina: 可以可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure, sure.
Tasha: 监工什么
Tasha: Supervise what?
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:他们得得在进度上啊
Jake: They need to stay on schedule.
Jake:现在还挺乱的
Jake: It's pretty chaotic right now.
其他人：等我几分钟嗯
Others: Wait a few minutes, alright?
其他人：我有个快递三分钟就送到了
Others: I have a delivery coming in three minutes.
Jake:你有电吗
Jake: Do you have power?
Tasha: 那再慢慢走就就到了吧
Jake:你插个电吗
Jake: Are you plugging it in?
其他人：我的快递哦
Others: My package is here!
Jake:你让修硕
Jake: Ask Shure to help you.
其他人：嗓子有点痛哦
Jake:买点药
Jake: Buy some medicine.
Jake:买一点点
Jake: Just a little bit.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:你这个信偏方了.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 找不到包了
Tasha: Can't find the bag.
Jake:找不到包
Jake: Can't find the bag.
Tasha: 肯定可以来得及的
Tasha: We can definitely make it in time.
Tasha: 一个小时肯定
Tasha: In an hour, for sure.
Jake:好好好我拿一个拿一个拿一个
Jake: Okay, okay, I'll grab one, grab one.
Lucia: 就他不是
Lucia: He's not...
Lucia: 一整张画
Lucia: It's a whole picture.
Lucia: 他是一个一个的
Lucia: He's doing it piece by piece.
Lucia: 你可以自己组合着贴在不同的地方
Lucia: You can stick them together yourself, in different places.
Jake:再见古希腊
Katrina: 哈哈好的
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Jake:走没找着
Jake: Let's go, can't find it.
Jake:但是你可以用我的剑
Jake: But you can use my sword.
Jake:你要修硕给你取
Jake: Want Shure to get it for you?
Tasha: 什么东西啊
Tasha: What is it?
Jake:你要你要先吃是吧
Jake: You want to eat first, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你要先吃就更等不了你了
Tasha: If you eat first, we really can't wait for you.
Jake:那走了
Jake: Let's go then.
Jake:啊好
Jake: Ah, okay.
Jake:是这样吗
Jake: Is that right?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:31号
Jake: Number 31.
Jake:31号 对啊
Jake: Number 31, right.
其他人：对
Others: Yeah.
Tasha: 那个人又在哪
Tasha: Where's that person?
Tasha: 你是取过吗
Tasha: Have you picked it up before?
Jake:我取过
Jake: I have.
Tasha: 你知道在哪吗
Tasha: Do you know where it is?
Jake:我知道的
Jake: I know.
Tasha: 你记住路了
Tasha: You remembered the way.
Jake:我记住了
Jake: I remembered.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe.
Tasha: 精品床头
Tasha: Premium headboard.
Tasha: 然后这么走
Tasha: Then go this way.
Jake:忘了可能是
Jake: Forgot, maybe.
Tasha: 你最好没骗我
Tasha: You better not be lying to me.
Jake:放心有执法记录仪
Jake: Don't worry, there's a law enforcement recorder.
Jake:你怎么买
Jake: How did you buy...
Jake:你买了这么多东西
Jake: You bought so much stuff.
Tasha: 那我肯定要把500块钱花完呀哈哈
Tasha: Of course, I had to spend all 500 bucks, haha.
Tasha: 而且我的性价比很高的
Tasha: And I got a lot of value for my money.
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
Tasha: 我都没有买名牌
Tasha: I didn't buy any brand names.
Tasha: 有个人买了一只兔子就买了300块钱
Tasha: Someone bought a rabbit for 300 bucks.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:好的
Jake:谢斌竹应该搭着这个车来
Jake: Xie Binzhu should be taking this car.
Tasha: 我们问他能不能坐上这车走
Tasha: Let's ask if we can get a ride.
Tasha: 载我一程
Tasha: Give me a ride.
Tasha: 给你一块
Tasha: I'll give you a buck.
Jake:他得咱俩人的话
Jake: If he says yes to both of us.
Tasha: 你下来我来骑
Tasha: You get off, and I'll ride.
Jake:对他下来咱俩上去
Jake: Yeah, he gets off, we get on.
Jake:哈哈他和谢斌竹一起吃药
Jake: Haha, he and Xie Binzhu take medicine together.
Tasha: 谢斌竹吃什么药
Tasha: What medicine does Xie Binzhu take?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:他说他有点小感冒
Jake: He said he had a cold.
Tasha: 小感冒我带感冒药了呀
Tasha: A cold? I brought cold medicine.
Jake:哇他带感冒药了
Jake: Wow, he brought cold medicine.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:他带感冒药了
Jake: He brought cold medicine.
Tasha: 我带了感冒药胃药发炎药消炎药
Tasha: I brought cold medicine, stomach medicine, anti-inflammatory medicine...
Tasha: 什么药都带了
Tasha: I brought all kinds of medicine.
Jake:今日破防
Jake: Today, I'm at my breaking point.
Tasha: 没有人问我呀
Tasha: Nobody asked me.
Tasha: 我胃药也带了
Tasha: I also brought stomach medicine.
Tasha: 我甚至掉了健胃消食片
Tasha: I even dropped my digestive tablets
Tasha: 我怕我们吃太多了
Tasha: I'm afraid we ate too much
Jake:见到你之后基本上每天得喝8个
Jake: After meeting you, I basically need to drink 8 every day
Tasha: 我以为你在吃饭
Tasha: I thought you were eating
Tasha: 我想着吃饭就不等你了
Tasha: I figured I'd eat without waiting for you
Jake:买都买
Jake: Just buy it
其他人： 你带的可能没有我想吃的对吧
Jake:哈哈哈回去我买的头孢
Jake: Haha, I bought some cefalexin
其他人：我买的头孢
Others: I bought some cefalexin
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm
Tasha: 哦哦哦我带的是儿童冲剂颗粒
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
其他人：我买的对了
Others: I bought the right one
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Whoa
其他人：姐你说我今天彩票能中奖吗
Others: Sis, do you think I can win the lottery today?
Tasha: 这会路过一家彩票店
Tasha: We're passing by a lottery shop
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 不知道我彩票最高就中过100块钱
Tasha: I don't know, the most I've won is 100 bucks
其他人：你想让我干什么就干什么哈哈哈
Others: You can ask me to do anything you want, hahaha
Tasha: 那我们去刮张彩票吧
Tasha: Then let's go scratch a lottery ticket
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人：姐让我刮我一定的刮
Others: Sis, if you let me scratch it, I will for sure
Jake:拿ego币和你换
Jake: I'll trade you some ego coins
Jake:一个ego币14,000
Jake: One coin is 14,000
Jake:啊哈啊
Jake: Aha
其他人：这是我们的未来期待
Others: This is our future expectation
Tasha: 彩票店对他说
Tasha: Tell him at the lottery shop
Tasha: 那我把店给你吧行吗
Tasha: 画一张大7
Tasha: Draw a big 7
Tasha: 选尾号10的
Tasha: Choose the number ending in 10
Tasha: 嗯十十一二十
Tasha: Mm, ten, eleven, twenty
其他人：啊 7
Others: Ah, 7
其他人：你讲那个啊
Others: You mean that one?
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right
Tasha: 刮那张大7
Tasha: Scratch that big 7
Jake:什么什么大7
Jake: What, what big 7?
Tasha: 福彩
Tasha: Lottery ticket
Tasha: Welfare lottery
Jake:大7是什么
Jake: What's the Big 7?
Jake:就是c罗那个7
Jake: It's like Ronaldo's number 7.
Jake:哦体彩
Jake:你也爱刮
Jake: You like scratching too?
Tasha: 嗯不爱刮
Jake:但
Jake: But
其他人：你好久没回国你知不知道彩票店是最火爆的
Jake:是我不知道为什么
Jake: Really? I had no idea why.
其他人：彩票店要排队
Other: People have to queue up at lottery shops.
Jake:这大家这么闲
Jake: Everyone has so much free time?
其他人：就是每个人都缺钱
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Wow
Jake:开始薅彩票羊毛了
Jake: Starting to milk the lottery now.
Tasha: 薅彩票的羊毛啊嗯
其他人：我怎么感觉现在哪里彩票店都火呢
Other: I feel like every lottery shop is popular now.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 我还了解了一下开彩票店的资质
其他人：我还真认识一个朋友大学毕业
Other: I actually have a friend who opened one right after college.
Jake:开彩票店赚多
Jake: Do lottery shops make a lot?
Tasha: 把体彩和福彩同时干下来
Tasha: He runs both sports and welfare lotteries.
其他人：他一毕业就开了一个彩票店
Other: He opened a lottery shop right after graduation.
Tasha: 一般都是打打票赚的钱多
Tasha: Usually, printing tickets makes more money.
Tasha: 刮刮乐赚的少
Tasha: Scratch cards make less.
Jake:嗯你家那个狗狗是
Jake: Hmm, your dog is...
Jake:吧嗯
Jake: Right, hmm.
其他人：他说有打火机
Other: He said he had a lighter.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：他说直接给我
Other: He said he'd just give it to me.
其他人：我就觉得很不好意思
Other: I felt really awkward.
其他人：我就直接给他递烟
其他人：哦我不想要他的烟
Other: Oh, I didn't want his cigarette.
其他人：他的烟太便宜了非要给我递烟
Other: His cigarettes are too cheap, but he insisted on giving me one.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:不给你打火机
Jake: He didn't give you the lighter?
其他人：给了
Other: He did.
Jake:给了吗给了
Jake: Did he? He did.
Tasha: turn left all right
Tasha: Turn left, all right.
Jake:都行都行都可以
Jake: Anything's fine, really.
Jake:真的都可以
Jake: Seriously, anything is fine.
Tasha: 全部都是自建房
Tasha: All are self-built houses.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 10年前我们家那也这样
Tasha: 10 years ago, our place was like this too.
Tasha: 自建
Tasha: Self-built.
Tasha: 怎么北京还能自建
Tasha: How can you still self-build in Beijing?
Jake:卧槽这车有点牛逼
Jake: Whoa, this car is pretty awesome.
Jake:就哈利波特
Jake: Just like Harry Potter.
Jake:哈利波特自建房
Jake: Harry Potter's self-built house.
Tasha: 哦什么魔芋
Tasha: Oh, what about konjac?
Tasha: 魔魔魔芋爽
Tasha: Mo-mo-mojac delight.
Jake:魔术麦吉克薇拉
Jake: Magic Mike's villa.
Tasha: 魔术
Tasha: Magic.
Tasha: magical
Tasha: Magical.
Jake:魔术哦
Jake: Magic, oh.
Jake:魔术还没建完
Jake: The magic house isn't finished yet.
Jake:还没建建一半
Jake: It's only halfway built.
Tasha: 哇哦
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:在左边右边一起建
Jake: Building on both sides.
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: So awesome.
其他人：他左边应该建好
Others: The left side should be finished.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
其他人：左边建好了
Others: The left side is finished.
Jake:可能不打通呵呵
Jake: Maybe it's not connected, haha.
Tasha: 不打通
Tasha: Not connected.
Tasha: 哇这个
Tasha: Wow, this.
Jake:白宫
Jake: White House.
Jake:White House
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:ai
Jake: Ai.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
Jake:我一个ego币
Jake: I have an ego coin.
Tasha: 我不行我不认识
Tasha: I can't, I don't recognize it.
Jake:ego币炒ego币
Jake: Trading ego coin for ego coin.
Jake:叫他逮起来
Jake: Call him to catch him.
Tasha: 可是
Tasha: But.
Tasha: 这事要经过你同意了吗老板
Tasha: Does this need your approval, boss?
Jake:我的钱
Jake: My money.
Tasha: 他说他是偷偷买币
Tasha: He said he secretly bought the coin.
Jake:中央银行
Jake: Central bank.
Tasha: 我靠那你不日夜一夜暴富了好吧
Tasha: Wow, then you won't get rich overnight, right?
Tasha: 根本就没有人找你买是吧
Tasha: No one is buying from you, right?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 那这个一个币
Tasha: So this is one coin
Tasha: 你你们预估的是多少钱呢就是
Tasha: How much did you guys estimate it to be?
Tasha: 就是你们给他定价是吗
Tasha: Did you guys set the price?
Tasha: 然后自己要把钱充进去是吗
Tasha: And then you have to put the money in yourself, right?
其他人：400块钱
Others: 400 yuan
Tasha: 买了150个币啊
Tasha: Bought 150 coins, huh?
其他人：买了一对土鸡
Others: Bought a pair of native chickens
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah